mesdemoiselles mesdemoiselles un petit
lens s'il vous plaît pendant les deux
années que nous allons passer ensemble
une institution ménagères vanderbeek de
vos futurs professeurs et moi même à
nous avons la délicate mission de faire
de vous la perte des ménagères rotation
toujours dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre la bonne épouse est avant
tout la compagne de son mari ce qui
suppose oubli de soi et une bonnes
moeurs arrête les to value lingots 24
ans de vie commune c'est quoi ce fameux
cds puis si je pense tous imprimés
passer la seconde
femmes en voiles au regard autour non tu
vas pas t'y mets toi aussi
mais sans ces groupes nous arriverons à
sauver l'école je vais me brillon
j'avais un carnet de chèques
bonne épouse se concentre sur ses tâches
ménagères tu veux te voir
afin de ne pas céder à toutes ces
tentations
en deux mots nous occuper mauvaises
pensées chasser l'air et diamant fer
qu'elle va monter à paris on ferme les
féministes les corps féministe c'est
qu'ils les femmes qui veulent être des
égards désolante ont fait des dépôts
niche comme vous je me dire où je vais
et qu'il est prêt je pas toujours le
scalp de faire ma vie avec toi
si ça peut te rassurer je suis anna du
repassage est tous très bien la cuisine
c'est faire la cuisine toi
[Musique]